字幕: T. Yamamoto
校正: 穎君 紀
皆さんは ありのままの姿としての
等身大の自分を偽って
理想の仮面をかぶっているというふうに
自分たちのことを感じたことはあるでしょうか
あるいは 他者や社会に
受け入れられやすいように
自分の姿を偽った仮面の裏で
誰も等身大の自分のことを
わかってくれていない
というふうに
孤立感を感じたことはないでしょうか
あるいは 最初は戦略的に
みずからかぶることにした仮面が
思いもよらない負の効果を
自分にもたらし
周囲の期待の中で
その仮面を脱ぐこともできなくなって
戸惑った
という経験はないでしょうか
素顔の自分と仮面の自分
そして 社会や他者との間に生じる
緊張関係を理解する上で
「依存症」と呼ばれる困難を
抱えている人々の語りは
とても参考になると私は考えてきました
依存症　たとえば
過度なアルコールやたばこの使用
あるいはギャンブルがやめられない
特定の 自分や他人を傷つける
人間関係のパターンを繰り返してしまう など
長期的に見ると 健康面や社会的な立場
あるいは経済的な状況に
悪影響を与えるということがわかっているのに
その習慣をやめることができない状況
これを広い意味での
「依存症」と呼ぶことがあります
これまでの膨大な研究によると 過去に
たとえば虐待ですとか いじめといった
対人関係における
深い傷つきを経験してきた人は
その後 依存症になりやすい
という事実も報告されています
ではなぜ 傷つきの体験が
依存症につながることがあるのでしょうか
少し留保をしたいのは 全員がそういう背景を
持っているというわけではないということです
あくまでも確率の問題です
傷つきの体験が依存症につながる
その因果関係を理解するためには
私は データだけではなくて
当事者一人一人の語りに
耳を傾ける必要があると考えてきました
こちらに今 お示ししているのは
女性の薬物依存症の
当事者の方が書いた 当事者研究の本
これは本当にすばらしい本です
『その後の不自由』という本です
基本的にはこの本の中に書いてあることを
今日は抜粋する形で 皆さんに
その一部を紹介したいと考えているのですが
まず皆さんご存じのとおり 人間という動物は
とても弱い動物ですね
さまざまな人やモノに依存しなくては
とても生きていかれません
それは 障害があろうがなかろうが
実は 同じです
［４つの依存先］
このスライドでは
一人の人間が生きていく上で
依存することができる いわば「資源」を
４つに分類してみたものです
一つ一つ説明をしてみましょう
１つ目は 水平な人間関係です
どういう意味かといいますと
たとえば親子や友人関係など
互いに相手を 自分と同じ
「人間」という種として
対等に見ている人間関係
のことを表しています
２つ目が 垂直的な人間関係です
これはたとえば カリスマ的な人物や
逆に 自分の言いなりになるような
立場の弱い他者など
そういった対等でない人間関係を
総称したカテゴリーです
そして３つ目は アルコールや薬物
その他 食べ物もそうかもしれませんが
こういった「物質」です
そして最後 ４つ目は「自分自身」です
虐待やいじめを経験すると
人間不信に陥るだけではなくて
先ほど挙げた ４つの依存先の
カテゴリーのうちの １つ目
すなわち水平な人間関係に
依存することが 必然 怖くなります
その結果 ２番目、３番目、
４番目の依存先への
依存の度合い 割合が過度に高くなります
特に ４つめの「自分への依存度」が
高くなる いわば ―
今日はちょっと造語を使わせていただくと
「自分依存」と
呼ばせていただきたいと思いますが
この自分依存の状態というのは
とても苦しいものです
自分依存 どういう状態かといいますと
「他人は信用できない」という孤立感とともに
他人に依存などしなくても生きていけるように
たとえば自分の頭の良さ
能力 腕力 見た目の良さ
こういった 自分に帰属できる資源を
向上させ続けようと 強迫的に努力すること
これを「自分依存」と呼びたいと思います
自分依存状態は いわば
等身大の自分にムチを打ち続けて
より上質な仮面を追求し続ける
苦しさを生み出します
ここで依存症と 今回のイベントの
テーマの「仮面」がつながるわけです ―
「自分依存」というキーワードによって
さて 皆さんは１番目から４番目までの
依存先それぞれに対して
おのおの どれぐらいの割合で
依存しているでしょうか
４つのバランスが取れた状態で
努力するのであれば
それはいいことかもしれません
しかし ４番目の自分依存の割合が
１つ目の水平な人間関係への依存を
大きく上回るような状況では
過度な自己責任論や
能力主義に陥ることでしょう
依存症を持つ人々の語りからは
この４つの依存先を分散させることの大切さを
理解することができると私は感じてきました
依存先を分散させることの重要さは
「依存症」とされる人々だけではなく
私のような 身体障害を
持っている人々にとっても
とても重要なテーマです
こちらの写真は 2011年3月11日
何の日か 皆さん
覚えていらっしゃるでしょうか
そう 東日本大震災が起きた日です
その日に撮影した写真となります
あの日 私は６階建ての建物の
５階におりました
早く逃げなくてはならないと思いましたので
この 今 乗っている電動車いすで
エレベーターのところまで移動し
下に降りるためのボタンを押したのですが
ボタンが点灯しませんでした
震度が大きかったため 安全装置が作動し
エレベーターが止まってしまったのですね
「ああ これで逃げ遅れてしまう」と
頭が真っ白になりました
ちょうどそのとき 幸運なことに
研究室の同僚が駆けつけてきてくれました
私が乗っている電動車いすは
重さが200キログラム近くありましたので
とても人の力では運べないですし
それを運んでしまっていたのでは
みんなで逃げ遅れてしまいかねませんでした
私たちは電動車いすを置き去りにして
私の体だけを 階段で運ぶことにしました
この写真は そのときに撮影したものです
私は避難先で移動の手段を失った ―
移動を可能にする電動車いすという
依存先を失ったわけですが
あの日 移動を可能にする依存先を失ったのは
何も私だけではありませんでした
地震の直後 都内の鉄道は
ほとんどすべて止まりました
そういう意味では皆 障害があってもなくても
平等に震災は影響を及ぼしたのですが
とはいえ そこに格差もあったわけです
［健常者］
たとえば健常者は エレベーターが
止まったならば階段を使う
体力があれば ロープやはしごを使っても
逃げることができる
という いわば「逃げる」
という 一つの行為を可能にする依存先が
複数 確保されていたわけです
一方で 私のように
車いすに乗った障害者の依存先は
エレベーターに
いわば「独占」されていたわけです
［障害者］
このスライドでは 依存先の数の
多い 少ないを 矢印の本数で表してみました
さて 同じスライドを
今度は矢印の太さに注目して
もう一度見ていただきたいと思います
この矢印の太さは
依存度合いの深さを表しています
健常者の場合 依存先の数が
相対的に多いおかげで
「あれがダメなら
これがあるではないか」という
依存の安定性を享受できているわけです
したがって エレベーターが止まったとしても
慌てずに進むことができます
これは エレベーターに支配されることなく
依存度が浅い状態を意味しています
しかし 障害者の場合 依存先が
エレベーターに限定されているせいで
エレベーターが止まったら
もうおしまいだ
という不安定な状況に置かれやすいわけです
一般的な傾向として 依存先の数の多さと
一つあたりの依存先への依存度の深さ
この関係は「一方が増えれば他方が減る」
という関係にあると考えられます
さて この社会は健常者や男性異性愛者など
いわゆるマジョリティ性を多く持っている人に
多くの依存先が分配されています
「障害者の方が依存している」
「健常者の方が自立している」
そんなことを言われることは
少なくありませんが
依存先の数で比べると 逆だということですね
あるいはさらに言えば 社会が依存先を
多く分配している人々のことを
「マジョリティ」と呼んでいる というのが
より正確な表現かもしれません
さて ここまで見てきたように
多くのモノや人への依存というのは
人間が生きていく上で必要不可欠なものです
にもかかわらず 不思議なことですが
私たちは とりわけ「他者」に依存することが
あたかも悪いことであるかのように
感じさせられがちです
依存を たとえば自立の対義語のように捉え
依存することは自立した一人前の人物に
なりきれていない証拠であるかのように
思ってしまうということも少なくないでしょう
しかし 本当の 人間らしい自立とは
決して「依存しない」ということと
イコールではありません
そもそも「依存しない」ということは
弱い人間という動物にとって
不可能と言えます
そうではなく 特定の依存先から
支配されることなく
豊富な依存先から依存を選択できること
すなわち 矢印で表現するならば
細くて多い矢印がたくさんあること
［自立の必要条件］
これが自立の 少なくとも必要条件と言えます
英語の「依存 (dependence)」
という言葉の意味の
歴史的変遷を調べた
ナンシー・フレイザーという研究者がいます
フレイザーによると「依存」という概念は
近代以前は悪い言葉ではなかったのだそうです
しかし 近代以降は望ましくない
状態を指すものとされるように
その意味が変わったと述べています
それとともに依存というのは
美徳から「病理」に変わり
それと並行して「依存症」という
疾患カテゴリーが広まっていきました
素顔の自分の価値や尊厳を
無条件に承認してくれる
宗教の力が弱まった近代以降
自分の価値を確認するためには
他者に承認してもらうしかなくなりました
そして 他者に承認してもらうためには
いかに自分が他者や社会の
役に立っているかを表す
仮面をかぶる必要が出てきたわけです
みなさんの中には こうした説明を聞いて
就職活動の場面を思い起こした方も
いらっしゃるかもしれません
近代の人間にとって「他者」は
家族や友人などの一部の人間関係を除き
依存先などではなく ライバルか
さもなくば自分の価値を見定めてくる評価者か
そのどちらかになってしまったとも言えます
このスライドに示した人物は
近代と依存症との共犯関係を
暴いてきた研究者たちです
［ベイトソン　ギデンズ　斉藤学　野口裕二］
さて ここまでの話で 依存症を
水平な人間関係に
安心して依存できなくなること
そしてそれ以外の関係性や物質に
依存先が過度に限定 独占されていくこと
として説明してきました
素の自分のまま依存できて
受け入れてくれる他者の存在が
ごく一部の人間関係に限られ
多くの場面で 理想とする自分の仮面を
かぶらなければいけないと感じてしまう
そういう意味で 実は近代に生きる人全員が
程度の違いこそあれ
広い意味での「依存症」であると
先ほどの研究者たちは述べているわけです
では 依存症的な孤立と
自己欺瞞（ぎまん）から脱し
水平な人間関係における相互依存を
回復するにはどうしたらいいでしょう
そのヒントも 依存症の人々が教えてくれます
薬物依存症の自助的な回復施設である
「ダルク」の創設者 故・近藤恒夫氏は
自分の無力さを自覚し
依存の必然性に気づいたところから
回復が始まると述べています
そして そこから仮面を脱いで
等身大の自分たちを認め合える
水平な人間関係づくりが始まるのです
［近代的な自分から降りる］
私は こうした相互依存に基づく
人間関係を構築できることは
他の動物にはない 人間にとっての
最大の強みだと考えています
個は弱くとも 相互依存の豊かさによって
組織や社会の水準で
大きな価値を生み出した結果
現代の豊かさがあるのだとも感じています
現在 私たちは 等身大の自分を
深く知り 互いに知り合う
当事者研究という手法を洗練させ
企業や大学・官公庁など
いわば近代を象徴する
さまざまな組織の中に実装することの
効果検証研究を始めたところです
受験から就活に至る過程で 私たちの中には
すっかり依存症的な価値観が
刷り込まれているといえるかもしれません
しかし 人々の健康と豊かな社会は
先ほど述べた４つの依存先の
バランスを保つことで実現します
仮面を脱いだ互いの等身大の姿を
安心して共有でき
互いに依存し合える 水平な人間関係を
増やしていく必要があると言えるでしょう
ご清聴ありがとうございました
（拍手）